there's a lot of you know I am known as
one of the MacGregor farm boys on
YouTube you know what I mean I've stuck
up for this guy a lot probably top three
dream interviews on the podcast like I
really wanted to get this guy on one day
enough of purposefully and I'll admit
this avoided criticizing him at some
time in the hope that it wouldn't [__]
it over for us in the future well that
ends today I'm about to kiss that
interview goodbye because the guys just
indefensible at this point like what the
[__] can I say punch an old men in pubs
I've tried defending him so many [__]
times you have inspired so many young
kids to take up martial arts to be a
batter
when they've been getting bullied like
you were bullied in Dublin I'm gonna
look after myself I'm gonna make
something of myself and the performance
is that you gave across your career
the Chad Mendes fight when you are
injured you were bruised you were bad
you were down but you weren't out and
you got that up and you showed the heart
of a lion you sure that you were a
[__] champion and then you were
surrounded by your family afterwards
what a moment I bought into it you are
like me a regular working-class guy who
just wanted to look after his family
give them a better life and prove all
the haters wrong and when after that
things got you know difficult as a fart
you'd lose it fights you know support
you through it these things are gonna
happen it doesn't matter win or lose we
are there for the right and even then
when you didn't even want to fight
anymore we weren't even gonna hardly say
unless you're flush and a Rolex on
Instagram I forgave you [__]
II wouldn't he's got the money go ahead
then it got a bit harder you know what I
mean there was someone X where I'm like
ah I'm just not gonna [__] say no I'm
just gonna leave it because not that bad
cheating on his wife it's a couldn't
move it is a [__] move but you know many
successful men have done it and it is
hard when you get that famous you've got
women throwing themselves at you I've
got no doubt about it
she's forgiving them it's none of our
business let them get on with it then
the rape allegations again you're
surrounded by women Cristiano Ronaldo
Chris Brown Neymar they've all had it
like when you get that level of success
and money and fame these sort of things
come with it unfortunately and he's
innocent until proven guilty I haven't
said anything about these things because
they're all private matters and we don't
really know the full story when it comes
to this you're in a pub and you offer in
a [__] shot of an old guy and he
probably tells your whiskey [__] you're
a [__] professional fighter
you're a lethal
and a legend in MMA there's a way of
conducting yourself there's a way of
laughing things off he's a little old
man you don't punch her in the [__]
face everything that you started MMA for
to defend yourself to defend your family
to be a better person you just shut all
over it and everyone who's defended you
amongst all the criticism all the
[__] you've done in the past he's a
cocky arrogant one no no it's just the
character is actually a pretty good guy
you know you don't understand we all
look like [__] idiots now but you
look like the biggest [__] idiot I'm
good that's someone I looked up to would
act in such a couldn t way punching a
little old man like that I'm like [__]
me man what the [__] are you on meat
like just beat let's be real yeah what
are you on what are you doing you're a
very hard man no doubt about that
punching a little man like that in a pub
proved nothing and the saddest thing
about it is it's the first [__] fight
you've won in three years I'm more
annoyed that over the years a lot of
people have said that this is the type
of law he is and I've thought now of
what so many interviews with hermès
documentary I've consumed every bit of
content that come out about this guy and
I really felt like you know you get a
good idea of who someone is then and
it's just ruined it because now whenever
someone says anything about McGregor I
can't say nothing now I can't defend
can't say nothing because those actions
are indefensible and it just adds weight
to every single thing anyone's ever said
against them and he is proven the haters
right unfortunately
that's up